right what else you got jen here we go
so pope francis is fairly new to
instagram
he joined i believe a few months ago
beginning of the year
and the i don't know but the other day
whoever is his account he liked this
photo
from a instagram model you can't blame
him god is good god
god good old pope francis he got 72
million already
yeah he got a lot of followers of course
someone's going to post that
but i want whoever's running his account
what the [ __ ] did he do
i thought it was god yeah he's not
running it you think the pope is in his
office like this
getting hate intern that was probably
like god yeah
what he said on friday the lord is my
shepherd and he know what i want
god doggity so what happened if they put
out a statement
no the intern just unliked it and uh
nobody's made it
posted this earlier today so i think it
just happened or it's going to be fake
it could be that's actually a funny
thing to do well you can easily fake
what's on instagram
she might have faked it because look how
many people are going to profile now
yeah
very fast that's the type of true yeah
yeah that's a good move right there i
see what you did
she is first team all bad yeah he knows
how to use two
c's on that thick by the way because
they use three they gotta
no material but she got that body my
question
with her strictly doing this right
what's her
what's her longevity wow but this is her
[ __ ] this is her brain
what's her longevity a lot like who is
the [ __ ] oh
she got it what is she gonna do though
you know like she's probably maybe she
has a clothing line
yeah that's what she got a business
manager put this away you go
earn this money she probably has skinny
teeth up the ass i was about no
what they drink yeah these women they
model their clothes now and they pay you
a certain
uh percentage you know yeah she's making
she's
making money yeah so like instagram
models now technically are
models it used to be kind of like a
running joke like if you're an instagram
model you're just an average girl with a
camera phone
but now you get paid for by the way but
not to cut you off but
with that these are the real models yeah
oh yeah my phone
models don't make money yeah models real
models don't like
traditional models don't make money they
don't this is
this is hot this is this is work this is
all what we want to see too i need to
change my instagram up [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
chappelle are you gonna get those cheeks
get those thick cheeks
you think it's that easy thing but by
the way huh know what you just said
that's exactly what i say about this too
like this like all you girls out there
like see bang bang bang i love bananas
but nobody drinks bang i know but
i know all these chicks out here that
think like
like they're right they're looking
they're shaming these girls that do this
hey
curry you can't do it exactly nobody
gives a [ __ ] about your bikini picture
no
exactly there's a reason why there's a
reason why she has 2.2 million followers
dudes actually
a lot of women follow women these women
yeah i'm sure because they
for different reasons yeah yeah yeah
yeah whatever it is like whatever that
thing is it's like so don't knock these
people for doing but
that guy said it's not easy like i
always hate i always hate when people
hate on the kardashians
i love kardashians kim kardashian ain't
regular
fine hell no what is she she fine fine
say it again for the view so it's kylie
[Laughter]
you ain't fine like that thank you all
right and then they go well they got
work done
all right let me tell you something
that's like putting rims on a s-class
mercedes don't do that you ride fast
dope on the lot yeah all right so all
that's a bar
all you corollas out there
no this is the same argument it's like
oh barry bonds only good because you're
on steroids
very cool take the same steroids and try
and hit that ball let me know
let me know how many home runs you hit
by the way no that's actually even a
better example of what i'm saying
yeah he was hall of fame that's what i'm
saying pre-steroids yes
he had he was a seven-time golden globe
he was dope on the line
he was dope on the line but he was like
you know what
some leather so i'm saying like so don't
be mad like so like that empire that has
been created they're all fine
yes it's kind of fine there's a reason
yes
you know what i mean they all they dope
and they have something about them they
got that thing
that flame so all these people at home
like this you know this is ridiculous
oh they got work done you get work done
yeah let me know if let me know how it
goes for you
get your nose done and your ass done
like them and let me
know it'll work if you start if you get
a show on [ __ ] eat women that's the
girl that used to look like me
let's not talk about that queen hold on
i need to see that oh
she looks like you
[Applause]
she got off the lot and turned the
[ __ ] mercedes look at that so look at
it go through the picture with the gap
oh [ __ ] look how big she was so that was
chappelle
this is like this she's bad but you know
what this
there's a lot of people who are just
unhealthy
what did she want to go get surgery
though now look at her with jordan look
at her about side by side with a devin
booker
right there look at that that's a
different person oh is he dating her
no no no devin booker's with kendall
she's maximizing her
full potential correct i like we all can
get there i bet you if you like you know
we all like if
these two he he used to work out more
but he works out you know what i mean
you if you you and i if we got to our
maximum potential how would we look
you know what i mean you know what i
mean if i if i was like
you know what i mean if i wasn't looking
like a blob but if i was like he had
some muscles and [ __ ]
yeah like the rock would be hideous if
he wasn't you know
i see it now take this [ __ ] away yeah
i agree so i have no problem with people
like you know
finding that it's just hard to do but my
thing
you to your point like my thing is my
thing is with the rocks
my thing is with the rockets like you
know how much [ __ ] he's taken to and
puts in his body to look that way
how is that any different than what
kylie jenner's doing true they're both
doing [ __ ] to look different listen any
woman that's looking at kylie jenner
and talking [ __ ] while they're talking
[ __ ] i want them to take off their fake
lashes
their makeup and push up raw speak on it
they're fat jeans
yeah you know the the jeans the spanx
every girl got some jeans that make
their booty look a little better
and then they get out and they're waist
training
what happened even skinny and shaky
people they still they
they're still some kind of genes
we all got stuff to enhance the problem
with men is like
that all we got is that yeah you know
you know or some of us all we got is
like our personality yeah
like you know it's like so like we all
we i i would encourage people to get
there get there you know
my our problem in society right one of
my problems i have in society right now
is that we have this whole like idea
that like you know
body positivity means be unhealthy now
be okay with being unhealthy right
people then they go like this you got to
do it you know oh you know
be you be happy with what you look like
and then adele loses weight
and all of a sudden girl they talk
[ __ ]
she's not mad at me if lizzo lost weight
yeah people i know but my point is like
but yeah but then but there's another
side of people who are looking at adele
like
good for you yeah because it's a lot of
work like damn the dead
dedication longer you feel healthy and
then there's also a lot of people with
liz are like
she might have diabetes like this ain't
good like we got to figure this out
yes but would i get because like if
that's your queen that's your champion
if you love adele's because she was fat
and you're fat at home like
a girl a girl that looks like me can
make it so then when someone like that
loses weight you're like
hey what what happened yeah wake up call
[ __ ]
you lose weight at home eating a pizza
like adele
yeah follow the journey yeah it's big
[ __ ] out there bad
black guy now yeah she lost weight she
got skinny
rapper kiss let's be real she lost
weight but i mean
what what are you saying you see not you
don't you don't believe in i lost 30
pounds i still ain't ready for a tank
top
still she lost a lot of weight now you
got a tank top ready eric she lost a lot
of weight now
come on yeah
look it looks like she got some work
done on her face yeah she did but look
here that one is unhealthy skinny but
that's not what she really looks like
she oh she doesn't know i'm saying
oh yeah yeah that was probably right
after her cleanse
that one on her like she's more she's
swell she's still
nice thick oh [ __ ] look at her yeah just
in her jaws yeah she has worked
thick though yeah some of us she looks
unhealthy yeah yeah she lost too much
weight well that's what happens when
like
yo because your body's not used if your
body's used to like fat just laying on
you all the time
you know you have to she looks good she
looks so good it's good thick there that
yeah
good thing yeah still a plus size model
yeah right there sign me up
yeah yeah right there yeah yeah yeah
that's a plus-size model
because i think like size eight and up
yeah man it's
still like the regular chicks yeah still
it's still it's plus size oh i didn't
know
she looks great what i'm saying is this
what's wrong with that's great
why can't this be the inspiration
because it's too hard it's it's too hard
it's too much work it's a hard work it's
hard you know she's famous that's why
she lost weight the height of your
athletic prowess how many times a week
did you work out
i mean six i mean six out of the seven
that's what i'm saying and right now 37
now you're 37
so you right now at 37 if you don't work
out you probably work out three or four
times a week now i work out every day
you see
you walk out every day because this
[ __ ] is now a ham sandwich away
from being a fat [ __ ]
that's one chicken sandwich away and as
you get older you're starting to notice
that 100 percent like before you
i can get away with maybe a week not
anymore what the [ __ ]
is that because dude i'm over 40. i look
at a donut and my [ __ ] just you know
yeah it happened our bodies changed so
it takes constant maintenance most
people don't work out every day like the
way you work out every day
because you're probably doing it you
know you've got whatever you do that's
right like
burpees i tried bikes but that's cardio
stuff yeah but i'm saying when you if
you want to
for yeah so how often do you do like the
muscle definition workouts and that kind
of stuff rare twice i really only get i
jump on a bike and do like 25 30 minutes
so your body
what i'm saying to you is that means
that your body is going to change yep
a year from now you're going to look
completely different you know it's going
to you know and that's what happens it's
hard [ __ ] work
you know it's like man there's no
substitute for it either like diet and
all that like it sucks man
especially when we're on the road me him
started diet two weeks ago yeah went
terrible
we had chicken sandwiches yeah
she wants me thicker but you don't want
you out there with these hugs
how did you lose 30 pounds it was like
because i
we quarantined i had to start cooking
oh you stopped eating out yes i stopped
eating out after that
and when you i find that when you cook
at home you don't buy things that you
get at restaurants so i don't buy bread
you know i just don't find myself buying
like rolls to dip in
olive oil and butter at home
with that oil i'm not doing all that
yeah bringing a little thing of butter
keep them coming right there no one does
it
so and then that's like um i got one of
those like stun i got sun basket it's
one of those cooking things
and if you go to my instagram you can
get forty dollars off but um
instagram i'm gonna take a cut of that
yeah
they um so you go like you so i like i
have cooking like so
and i cook on instagram so that's me the
first one that i just cook in my little
kitchen i don't got bernie shout out
money
oh this is a 42 minute video yeah
because i just
i just make uh what did you make so i
made like some macaroon chicken or
something like that
and it's it's actually and the thing
about it is it's actually fun to cook
it's it's therapeutic
very enjoyable makes you enjoy the food
is that an emerald pan
or uh oh i got some non-stick pancakes
did you cook it in your sauce you're mad
at me that i was you oh yeah
i i'm not cooking i don't have one yeah
i got your chocolate
like you know but anyways so you know i
just that's
how i did it at first i just stopped and
then now i'm starting to walk every day
because what i realized is
losing weight doesn't make you healthy
let me just put that out there just
losing weight doesn't mean you're
healthy you could
especially at a certain age you could
still have issues with blood sugar
you can still have issues cholesterol on
that with your kidney and cholesterol
issues and all that kind of stuff so
you know you still have to get you look
that's the raccoon video right there i
was looking at him i was looking at that
right there
yeah that's the raccoon video you know
i'm trying to vote
rachel gets in the car yeah he said [ __ ]
this video rachel gets in the car close
the door i was like right y'all
where did you go
because most animals would be like this
they might scurry yeah he kept walking
he kept walking
hey [ __ ] yeah all right who you voting
for
like a tony baker video
shout out to tony baker so that [ __ ] is
like so anyways like i'm saying so i
that's how i did it i just
especially i i started with just like
looking at i'm eating less
and your girl's skinny on this yeah just
genetically yeah
yeah yeah yeah ectomorph skinny can he
whatever the [ __ ] she wants
she's a mom she's she's getting older i
have her on my podcast about now because
i haven't been having guests
was that her yeah yeah that's right
right there let me see your girl right
there
no down is that okay yeah that's my girl
no
she's oh okay i see you she's 31 by the
way
same age as my girlfriend
we just like went out in a limo with all
my friends
first and then she's just talking about
her prom day
okay one of the comments said damn she
fine
that's a little man you know why they
say that their own what their touch
subtext is
damn what you doing with her yeah
basically yeah
in contrast she's finer next to me but
maybe if you're
sitting next to like brad pitt it
wouldn't be the same oh
she's still fine though but anyway
congratulations anyway
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] uh